>> Mark: DESPITE SAUDI ARABIA --
ED WILL BE BACK LATER.
DESPITE SAUDI ARABIA'S MURDER OF
JAMAL KHASHOGGI, PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID HE WON'T BE TURNING AGAINST
THE COUNTRY.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT WAS
BLUNT ABOUT HIS REASONING BEING
FRIENDLY WITH THE SAUDIS IS IN
THE INTEREST OF THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
>> President Trump: I'M NOT
GOING TO TELL A COUNTRY THAT'S
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND HAS HELPED ME DO ONE
THING VERY IMPORTANTLY, KEEP OIL
PRICES DOWN SO THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO 100 AND 150 A BARREL.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE OIL PRICES IN
GREAT SHAPE.
I'M NOT GOING TO DESTROY THE
WORLD ECONOMY AND I'M NOT GOING
TO DESTROY THE ECONOMY FOR OUR
COUNTRY BY BEING FOOLISH, WITH
SAUDI ARABIA.
>> THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED DOWN
THAT PATH TWEETING, QUOTE, OIL
PRICES GETTING LOWER, GREAT.
LIKE A BIG TAX CUT FOR AMERICA
AND THE WORLD.
ENJOY, $54 WAS JUST $82.
THANK YOU TO SAUDI ARABIA BUT
LET'S GO LOWER.
NIGEL IS A FORMER LEADER OF THE
U.K. INDEPENDENT EVENS PARTY AND
THE DRIVING FORCE BEHIND BREXIT,
JOINING US FROM LONDON.
THE SAUDIS, EVEN THOUGH THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF LEADERSHIP IN
THE COUNTRY WAS IMPLICATED IN
THE MURDER, APPEAR TO HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT AS FAR AS
THE WORLD IS CONCERNED.
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
I DO UNDERSTAND, FOR THOSE IN
THE USA AND THE UK, SAUDI ARABIA
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MARKET TO
US.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
LINKED.
WITH SELLING AIRPLANES,
MUNITIONS.
I ALSO GET THE STRATEGIC
ALLIANCE WITH SAUDI ARABIA
AGAINST IRAN, YOU KNOW, WHO HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO SPREAD A VERY
EXTREME FORM OF ISLAMISM RIGHT
ACROSS THE REGION.
I UNDERSTAND THE REASONS FOR IT.
BUT IMAGINE IF ANY OTHER COUNTRY
BEHAVED LIKE THIS.
IF RUSSIA HAD BEHAVED LIKE THIS,
THERE WOULD BE A MUCH BIGGER
INTERNATIONAL OUTCRY.
MY REAL PROBLEM, MARK, IS THAT
IN THE WAKE OF THE SYRIAN
CRISIS, VAISH DID NOT TAKE A --
SAUDI ARABIA DID NOT TAKE A
SINGLE REFUGEE OR DISPLACED
PERSON.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO FUND THE
BUILDING 2600 MOSQUES IN
GERMANY.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN, IS IT'S BEING
SPREAD USING SAUDI MONEY.
FINE, LET'S GO ON DOING TRADE,
LET GOES ON HAVING STRATEGIC
ALLIANCES, BUT DON'T BE
FRIGHTENED TO BE CRITICAL OF THE
THINGS THEY DO.
>> Mark: SAUDI ARABIA'S
PRINCIPAL EXPORT ISN'T OIL, IT
IS IDEOLOGY.
THE OIL ENABLES THEM TO SPREAD
THAT IDEOLOGY AROUND THE WORLD1.
5 SAUDIS WILLED -- 15,000 SAUDIS
KILLED 3,000 AMERICANS ON 9/11,
PRESIDENT BUSH ASSURED US THE
SAUDIS ARE OUR FRIENDS.
WE HAVE A CROWN PRINCE, SENATOR
LINDSAY GRAHAM AND OTHERS SAYING
I PARTICIPATE INTERESTLY
UNSTABLE.
LIKE IN YOUR -- PATENTLY
YOU'RE JUST A COUPLE OF QUARTERS
FROM THE QUARTER ST. JAMES, THEY
DON'T HAVE PLACE IN THE PARTY OF
SAUDY DIDN'T WE REMOVE THIS GUY
AS CROWN PRINCE AND HAVE?
ONE ELSE AS CROWN PRINCE?
>> YES, YOU KNOW, MBS AS HE'S
KNOWN WAS SOLD TO US AS A GREAT
REFORMER.
THE TRUTH IS, THAT WOULD APPEAR
NOT TO BE THE CASE AT ALL.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE DOES APPEAR
TO HAVE DONE IS TO ASSUME THE
VERY UNPLEASANT WAR GOING ON IN
YEMEN.
MAYBE WE SHOULD THINK THAT SOME
OF THE BOMBS THAT WE'RE SENDING
TO SAUDI ARABIA ARE BEING USED
BY HIM IN THIS WAR.
SO, YOU'RE QUITE RIGHT.
MANY OTHER OPTIONS, EFFECTIVELY,
TO BE THE HEAD OF SAUDI ARABIA,
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND WHAT TRUMP
IS SAYING, I UNDERSTAND IN THIS
COUNTRY MRS. MAYS' RELUCTANT TO
BE CRITICAL.
BUT WE SHOULD BE SAYING AND
DOING MORE.
>> Mark: AND WE SHOULD ALSO BE
CLEARED, TOO, KHASHOGGI IS BEING
PRESENTED AS A HERO OF
JOURNALISM, PROBABLY GOING TO BE
"TIME" MAGAZINE MAN OF THE YEAR,
HE'S A DEAD SO-CALLED
JOURNALIST.
BUT HE WAS A DEEP STATE SAUDI
SPOOK WHO HAPPENED TO FALL OUT
WITH THE ROYAL FAMILY.
IN A SENSE, IT'S DIFFERENT SETS
OF BAD GUYS WE'RE ARGUING ABOUT.
>> WELL, OF COURSE IT IS.
BUT DON'T YOU THINK, ACTUALLY,
THE TRUTH IS ALL THROUGH THE
MIDDLE EAST WHETHER WE LOOK AT
IRAQ, OR LIBYA, OR SYRIA WE KEEP
ON PLAYING THIS GAME OF WHO ARE
THE GOOD GUYS AND WHO ARE THE
BAD GUYS.
AND MORE OFTEN THAN NOT WE TEND
TO GET IT WRONG.
>> Mark: IT IS THE OLD CIA LINE,
HE MAY BE AN SOB BUT HE'S OUR
SOB.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Mark: HE MAY BE OUR SOB BUT
HE'S STILL AN SOB.
THAT MAY BE THE TRUTH.
HAPPY THANKSGIVING.